the cats suffocated with carbon dioxide, my wife is
also being
resuscitated, and I was called by a neighbor who told
me to come because there was a leak in
our apartment. Well, I arrived and I
didn't even see my wife because she was already
taken to the hospital. She is there with her mother. And I am here
with
apartment, we managed to go down to the
shelter and got into the residential complex
and the wave caught our house,
all the windows were broken, but thank God, thank God we
are alive and healthy and that's the main thing
[music]
This is your room,
so where is
the dozhnara It was my grandmother, an
old woman, that's why I can't  to leave it somewhere
and
run, so we were in the corridor. And the
walls were shaking and the glass was
creaking. Well, of course, they were scared. Why did they
say that we should all get out now
?  there will be
such a big explosion, and it turns out that we, my mother, has
already run out and started shouting, like,
let's gather, like, gathered,
like, everyone
went out into the corridor at once, and already, like, at once.
this house started to
burn, something has already started to explode. I don't
know what exploded there, of course. Well, everything
started to explode, and now
the police came and said, leave the house for
two
hours.